boa tarde pessoal aqui hoje para a gente
bater um papo sobre algoritmos de
recomendação e pra isso eu vou convidar
vocês a se levantarem pra gente se
movimentar um pouco porque eu sei que
depois do almoço não é fácil e aí a
gente enche seu auditório de energia
antes de a gente começar a conversar
ah eu escolhi aqui uma música bem old
school pouquinho das antigas que acho
que a maioria deve conhecer aí que com
certeza vocês conhecem a coreografia
também pra gente poder dançar junto
beleza
vamos lá
[Música]
foi com alegria natalina que tudo foi
feito na linha com sua mãe na linha do
grupo alegria marina iria marcar e
alegria alegria maracanã
foi uma alegria uma brigada foi ótimo
mandaram bem não há clareza e até ficar
com vontade de continuar dançando aqui
eu vi gente então enquanto você se
acomoda e eu retomo aqui o meu fôlego
também eu tenho um segredinho para
contar pra vocês
a gente acabou de rodar aqui juntos um
algoritmo série a definição de algoritmo
é essa aqui são sequências finitas de
instruções bem definidas e não amigos
cada uma das quais deverão ser
executadas mecânica ou eletronicamente
em um intervalo de tempo finito e como a
quantidade de espaço esforço finita
ou seja toda vez que a gente executa uma
coreografia a gente está rodando um
algoritmo a mesma coisa quando a gente
cozinha seguindo uma receita culinária
ou ainda quando a gente aprende a usar
um novo equipamento seguindo o manual de
instruções
isso quer dizer que os algoritmos eles
fazem parte do dia-a-dia de vocês
independente de vocês trabalharem com
tecnologia ou não
e por que então que os algoritmos
computacionais tem recebido tanto
destaque ultimamente por um simples
motivo a gente vive uma era e inundada
por dados com a chegada da internet a
informação ela passou a circular
livremente pelo mundo e nessa nova
configuração em que a gente transita em
fluidez pelas interfaces do mundo físico
e do mundo digital a gente dispõe de
abundância de informação
a gente tem acesso a praticamente
conteúdo ilimitado sobre qualquer
assunto que a gente tem interesse
isso é incrível né
sim é maravilhoso mas tem um porém nossa
história o nosso cérebro ele continua
com recursos cognitivos limitados a
gente não dá conta de processar toda
essa informação
não disponível então pensa que há cerca
de 20 anos existia uma uma certa
sensação de ociosidade em relação ao
conteúdo que a gente tinha acesso e à
quantidade de informação a nossa
capacidade de processamento
à medida que esse volume de informação
foi aumentando a gente foi
experimentando as sensações de
empolgação e até um sentimento de poder
até que a gente começou a sentir os
efeitos dessa decidisse equilíbrio entre
o volume de informação ea nossa
capacidade humana de processamento ea
esse stress
a gente dá o nome de um fax queixa' ou
seja uma sobrecarga devido ao excesso de
informação que paralisa a nossa
atividade mental e dificulta a nossa
tomada de decisão
então se na era analógica a gente lia um
jornal e sentia que estava e atualizado
a respeito das notícias do dia
hoje a gente vive a angústia de nunca dá
conta de consumir todo o conteúdo que
chega até a gente
por via de agências de notícias redes
sociais ou até os grupos do a tap e
quais são as projeções para o futuro
será que existe alguma chance desse
volume de informações reduzir
é claro que não à medida que se amplia
que se expande a conexão digital da
humanidade essa avalanche de dados ela
se especializa se uma aumenta
exponencialmente e nesse contexto os
algoritmos ea sua evolução da
inteligência artificial eles surgem como
heróis para ajudar a gente a filtrar
informação e aliviar essa nossa rotina
constante de busca e seleção de conteúdo
relevante nesse contexto o ponto todo é
que a gente não tem um problema na
verdade de volume
nada de excesso de informação e
sim de formas e falhas com relação à
filtragem que a gente faz desses dados
e nessa forma a gente começa a entender
o papel social crucial que os algoritmos
de recomendação exercem nessa era do big
data
esses são sistemas que têm por trás como
de fome é estrutura de aprendizagem de
máquina onde a partir de dados
comportamentais
eles reconhecem padrões e repetições e
então eles nos entregam recomendações
aderentes ao nosso perfil para a gente
entender melhor isso vamos considerar um
exemplo bem simples como de um e
comércio
então a partir das cestas de compras de
diferentes usuários
o algoritmo ele reconhece na busca por
padrões de comportamento e então ele
define notas de associação entre esses
itens da loja e recomenda àqueles itens
que têm maiores notas a cada nova
interação na plataforma
então dessa forma a máquina reconhece
que quando os usuários compram losangos
eles geralmente compram também círculos
asteriscos
eventualmente eles com triângulos e
algumas vezes eles compram também
quadrados e então ele segue essa
estrutura analítica na hora de
recomendar um novo produto o usuário em
sistemas mas é sofisticados
a gente pode incluir também a interação
entre itens e a ocasião de consumo no
processo que pode recomendar um filme
pra assistir um sábado à noite sendo
diferente de um filme que eu vou
assistir numa quarta feira à tarde por
exemplo ea gente pode também pensar em
parâmetros que levem em conta a
descrição de atributos ou tags desses
itens
pensando por exemplo em filmes com
classificações devido ao seu nível de
dramaticidade ação ou ainda com relação
à a estrutura do roteiro construção dos
personagens ou seja todo o sistema que
está a portar se de um algoritmo
começam todas as recomendações que vem
desses algoritmos eles surgem de nós
mesmos ou seja é a decodificação do
comportamento humano cristalizado
através de camadas de ciência que
reconhecem evidenciam os nossos desejos
e nos entregam qualificação de conteúdo
e então tá a partir disso a gente começa
a receber indicações de produtos
interessantes pra comprar seriados ou
música para nos divertir e pode rolar
até mesmo uma ajudinha de um cupido
analítico na hora de encontrar um novo
amor
hoje entre 75 e 80 por cento do produto
o conteúdo assistido dentro da
plataforma netflix
ele tem origem em sistemas de
recomendação enquanto que 35% das
compras da amazon ela surgem de
indicações orientadas por dados e é
claro que o conteúdo que nós somos
expostos nas redes sociais também têm
origem nesse mesmo tipo de sistemas numa
ponderação de interesses dos indivíduos
da plataforma e também dos seus
anunciantes
nesse meio é bem recentemente a gente
acompanhou um caso bem polêmico de uso
de dados de usuários do facebook para
promover o engajamento político
direcionado nos estados unidos no reino
unido um caso em que os próprios
usuários autorizar uma empresa de
pesquisa a coletar os seus dados em
troca de um teste de personalidade
essa empresa então a partir dos dados
levantados de milhares de usuários
aplicou uma metodologia de segmentação
social conhecida como de bife que
classifica as pessoas conforme o seu
comportamento ao invés de variáveis
demográficas e a partir dessa
segmentação foram geradas notícias e
postagens direcionado
os interesses é por perfil de cada um
desses segmentos de usuários e com isso
foram recomendados e impulsionado os
conteúdos que geraram esse engajamento
político direcionado a esse caso ele nos
faz pensar que ele amplia os debates
sobre como os nossos dados são usados
faz a gente pensar sobre ética
transparência e equilíbrio consciência
o fato é que nós trocamos dados por
valor pra conseguir ter um conteúdo
personalizado a gente precisa entregar
dados sobre as nossas expressões
individuais e pra cá e pra isso quanto
mais informações mais precisas são essas
recomendações que essas estruturas
elas viram todas entre em cima de
desejos
elas têm uma escala que deveria ponderar
os interesses de pessoas e negócios
são sistemas que deveriam é equilibrar é
trazer um equilíbrio entre nos oferecer
mais do mesmo mais do que aquilo que já
se sabe que o usuário gosta
ao mesmo tempo que deveriam abrir abrir
portas para a diversidade para instigar
novos interesses novas visões são
questões sobre ajustes de parâmetros que
deveriam permitir explorar o conhecido
ao mesmo tempo que se lança para o
desconhecido
e aí a gente precisa questionar nós
mesmos
o quanto de pluralidade
a gente quer nas nossas vidas ou quanto
que a gente prefere permanecer
acomodados nos nossos microcosmos será
mesmo que você quer ser questionado ser
instigado por opiniões
notícias divergentes do seu pensamento
ou você prefere diz fazer amizade com
aqueles conhecidos no facebook que tem
opiniões opostas às ruas
o fato é que o ser humano é por natureza
um serviço usado o nosso comportamento
na esfera digital é simplesmente um
reflexo de quem a gente é no mundo
físico ea gente tem de sim a se
relacionar com pessoas que seguem linhas
de pensamento similares às nossas e a
rechaçar aquelas que são contraditórias
e dessa forma a cada curtida no mesmo
tipo de conteúdo a cada compartilhamento
do mesmo ponto de vista
a gente reforça o entendimento dos
algoritmos a respeito de quem nós somos
e nos encerramos cada vez mais em bolhas
criadas por nós mesmos
isso nos mostra com clareza o impacto
exponencial que a dualidade pode ter
nessa era da internet pois a gente soma
aos nossos vieses cognitivos a
capacidade multiplicadora dos algoritmos
computacionais e aí é preciso muita
atenção principalmente em épocas de
decisões coletivas que configuram os
rumos de uma nação
nas últimas eleições presidenciais nos
estados unidos observou se que notícias
falsas geraram um engajamento maior que
notícias de meios tradicionais
no período que antecedeu a votação num
exemplo de como os ânimos inflamam e na
ânsia da gente conseguir cobrar quando a
ânsia da gente conseguir comprovar o
nosso ponto de vista a gente
simplesmente perde a razão
por isso a tecnologia ela precisa
trabalhar para construir algoritmos
consenso de vida pública
preocupados em promover e entregar os
interesses dos indivíduos
ao mesmo tempo que promovem a
diversidade ea transparência
a gente precisa é de neutralidade de
ética tanto dos desenvolvedores quanto
dos usuários e para isso a gente precisa
formar consciência analítica saber da
nossa responsabilidade
ao fornecer dados e compartilhar
conteúdo ea gente precisa também
distribuir essas conversas para
diferentes camadas da sociedade para que
mais pessoas consigam entender essa era
de mudanças que a gente está vivendo
agora nós estamos todos juntos
construindo esse novo mundo
vamos agir para que ele seja plural
obrigado
[Aplausos]